[Música]
maquiagem no escuro sem espelho
impossível
gostaria de convidar a todos nesse
momento o teatro está todo escuro mas eu
gostaria que todo mundo fechassem os
olhos e começa assim a tocar o rosto de
vocês
começa assim pela testa sobrancelha
olhos nariz e bochechas boca e queixo
fossem sentindo com a ponta dos dedos
todo o contorno do rosto podem abrir os
olhos
vocês acabaram de experimentar um pouco
da sensação que o deficiente visual tem
ao se enxerga através da ponta dos dedos
boa tarde
meu nome é tênis briann e eu estou aqui
essa tarde pra falar pra vocês um pouco
sobre o beleza para todos um projecto
que nasceu para proporcionar
independência aumentar a autoconfiança
elevando a auto estima através do
empoderamento com a maquiagem
esse projeto ele tem três pilares o amor
a superação ea determinação vamos falar
um pouquinho agora de amor esse belo
casal que vocês estão vendo na tela é
minha grande amiga taís frota e o seu
marido deusdete é uma menina linda como
vocês podem constatar no vídeo e ela
nunca ligou muito para o mundo da
maquiagem
talvez por não perceber a diferença que
a maquiagem fazia na vida de qualquer
mulher
a taís nasceu com a mutação genética que
se chama marosi
hoje entende hleb que causa a perda
progressiva da visão e por isso nunca
conseguiu perceber a real diferença da
maquiagem
um dia estávamos numa viagem nós 4 ela
com na época noivo da sdet o meu marido
roberto e ela estava se sentindo com a
baixa autoestima e veio me pedir para
maquiar lá naquele momento ela realizar
o meu sonho porque eu sempre quis ver a
taís batom vermelho mas nunca tinha
conseguido até então
então ela deixou que eu a maquiar se
e o resultado foi tão incrível o noivo
ficou tão encantado ao ver lula o seu
amor tão mais bela com a maquiagem que
ficou elogiando elogiando e vocês sabem
homem na vida de mulher é uma desgraça
porque se o cara giz
tu tá bonita assim lá vai a pessoa quer
ficar bonita pra ele daquele jeito que
ele disse porque é agradar e assim não
foi diferente com a taís
só que ela sempre fui muito independente
e buscou sozinho vídeos na internet
procurou cursos específicos para
deficientes visuais
mas infelizmente não encontrou nada
foi aí que lembrou da amiga no caso eu
que sempre quis revelar maquiada e me
ligou e lançou um desafio eu me lembro
como se fosse hoje da ligação ela teme
se que até no caso quer como ela me
chama
eu tenho um desafio pra você eu quero
aprender a me maquiar e é você quem vai
ensinar não encontrei nada naquele
momento eu não tive a menor dúvida o
amor que eu sentia pela taís minha amiga
de infância era tão grande que eu não
titubeei eu nem pensei na possibilidade
de não conseguir disse taís vai dar
certo
tenho certeza que eu vou conseguir e
você vai aprender e naquele momento com
um desafio irmãos surgiu a superação
eu tinha que me superar porque eu sempre
tive a minha disposição todos os
recursos ao nosso deficiente visual
sempre x bilu e sempre tive espelho a
minha esposa
e aí foi comum eu fiz como vocês no
começo me coloquei no lugar escuro sem
espelho e comecei a tocar o meu rosto
assim como pedi pra que vocês o fizessem
e naquele momento vieram sensações
comecei a sentir as texturas dos
produtos de maquiagem tanto na palma da
minha mão quanto no meu rosto comecei a
adaptar as técnicas sempre com o uso das
mãos para facilitar essas sensações e no
final conseguiu me lembro como se fosse
hoje ao acender o espelho e ver que eu
tinha conseguido foi emoção assim tão
grande e naquele momento eu liguei pra
thaise desse amiga eu consegui você vai
ter seu curso de automaquiagem vem pra
cá que você vai que vai dar certo e ela
veio ao meu encontro e fui explicando
pra ela foi fazendo e no final ela tinha
conseguido foi emoção tão grande e que
eu vi o que a gente tinha realizado ela
não encontrava nada daquele conteúdo ea
gente tinha conseguido desenvolver e ela
tinha conseguido aplicar e aí eu lancei
um desafio para taís que a taís é muito
tímida
então eu lancei o desafio que eu falei
tá aí nós não podemos nós temos uma
responsabilidade aqui que nasceu agora
nós não podemos deixar esse conteúdo só
entre a gente
nós temos que compartilhar com as
pessoas eu já tinha um canal no youtube
então eu desafiei vamos gravar vídeo
para o youtube para que esse conteúdo
possa ser disponibilizado de uma forma
gratuita e atingiu o mundo todo porque
como vocês sabem a internet ela não tem
fronteiras
então ao jornal um conteúdo em qualquer
canal que seja internet instagram ele
atingiu todo o mundo então também foi um
momento de superação para taís mas como
era o intuito era ajudar outras mulheres
que assim como ela precisava desse
conteúdo ela topou e assim nasceu beleza
para todos os nossos vídeos
esse é o vídeo de capa
são oito vídeos no total hoje a gente
faz o passo a passo da maquiagem com a
narração detalhada acredito que muitos
aqui quando eu falei maquiagem para
deficientes visuais vídeo na internet
deficiente visual não enxerga mas eles
escutam muito tem baixa visão ainda
consegue enxergar então a narração neste
momento ela se torna primordial a
narração é bem detalhada a gente faz uma
linguagem acessível a gente
desmistificar todos os conceitos da
maquiagem com o que eu votei por a maçã
do rosto tudo isso é muito bem descrito
de forma realmente a simplificá esse
mundo da beleza e proporcionar uma
acessibilidade real a quem quisesse se
maquiar a acessibilidade também eu
lembro para muitos
existe uma legislação no brasil de 2015
que começou a virgem em 2016 que a lei
13.143 2015 que trata do estatuto da
pessoa com deficiência e no artigo 8º
ela coloca não só o estado mas também
traz a responsabilidade para a sociedade
e para a família garante a
acessibilidade global à pessoa com
deficiência também no sentido de bem
estar pessoal
será que cumprimos o nosso papel porque
não vemos tantas embalagens em braile ou
em alto relevo x ao ver mais medicamento
mais alimentos indústria de cosméticos
cadel braille cadê o alto relevo o quão
incrível seria a gente poder
proporcionar essa independência pra eles
eles pudessem escolher seus próprios
produtos
fica o questionamento agora entra o
próximo sentimento que eu disse pra
vocês que a determinação feito o amor
que foi o que levou a atriz a se
interessar e foi o que me moveu a
ajudá-la a superação tanto minha de
aprender as técnicas de conseguir
desenvolver da taís de aceitar o desafio
de se expor
eles podem fsi em cima dela a em rede
mundial vem a determinação para poder
levar o beleza para todos ainda mais
longe
e nesse momento tivemos a oportunidade
incrível de estar na globo com a cissa
guimarães não é de casa em dezembro
também podemos conhecer gravar com a
autoridade máxima quando o assunto é
beleza que é o meu amigo fernando
torquatto que inclusive está aqui
presente no auditório nos prestigiando e
naquele momento eu também senti depois
segundo momento uma necessidade premente
de sair um pouco do virtual de sair um
pouco das redes sociais um pouco de
televisão e baixe para o real
e aí entra o instituto dos cegos onde o
promovem curso prass deficientes visuais
de tudo saiba que muitas vezes não têm
acesso a esse conteúdo de internet e foi
tão incrível ver ele imediatamente uma
melhora na autoestima e no empoderamento
como vocês vão poder conferir neste
vídeo a sua maior felicidade estou muito
feliz porque é muito bom eu não saber se
a maquiagem ela fazia toda a diferença
ela foi assim uma pessoa de coração bem
aberta uma pessoa nos ensinou coisas que
a gente não sabia e não importa a sua
limitação essa dificuldade você pode ser
sim uma mulher linda uma mulher bela não
é preciso você apenas se olhar no
espelho o espelho é a sua alma é estado
chegou sem a beleza que talvez você
reflete fora eo a maquiagem é apenas um
complemento determinação também para
estar aqui hoje nesse palco
acredito que muitos devem saber eu sou a
única palestrante que não foi convidada
que foi escolhida pelas redes sociais
então representa o voto popular dos
vídeos que foram disponibilizados
através do instagram e facebook onde
concorria com outros dois fortes
candidatos e no dia exatamente no dia
final eu perdia com a diferença de duas
mil curtidas às 19 horas e 28 minutos
assim encerra às 23 horas e 59 naquele
momento
para muitos chegaram para mim a ficar
tranquila deixa pra lá
você já realizou muita coisa mas eu
sempre tive fé e sempre tive a certeza
que ia dar certo e eu encontrei uma
amiga minha munique nunes numa feira de
noivas aqui no rio mar que entrou na
campanha e pediu voto para mim e às 23
horas e 59 minutos de 4 mil curtidas eu
passei pra 10 mil curtidas foi uma
virada assim eu depois estratégia de
maratonista no final do spirit e
consegui então o que muitos parecia ser
impossível assim como a maquiagem no
escuro com deficientes visuais acredito
que para muitos de vocês também pareceu
impossível com se tornou possível com
amor com a superação e com a
determinação o que mostra que nada nessa
vida é por acaso eo meu coração essa
gratidão hoje está aqui com vocês
compartilhando desse projeto e poder
também ajudar a mulher a gente sabe que
a gente consegue realmente mudar a vida
das pessoas com pequenos gestos como
vocês já viram todas as palestras que me
antecederam
então agora para finalizar né eu sou o
youtube
eu tenho com o instagram então não posso
deixar de pedir pra todo mundo se
inscrever
kurt compartilhar todos os edis e me
siga no instagram
obrigado
[Aplausos]